bonjour le sergent chef adam à vous êtes
un soldat des forces spéciales
vous êtes un béret vert ah oui
je suis aussi membre de la garde
nationale alors on mai 2002 vous avez
été envoyés en afghanistan pour traquer
les membres d'al-qaida justement et vous
êtes revenu avec un livre coécrit avec
le capitaine alan hatch qui s'appelle se
livre sur les traces d'al qaïda c'est
publié chez albin édition voilà alors
c'est un témoignage de deux membres des
forces spéciales alors dès votre arrivée
en afghanistan vous découvrez des
problèmes de logistique des problèmes de
sécurité alors vous dites qui a passé de
soldat ça c'est quelque chose de très
important dans votre livre il ya qu'à
l'état major où il ya un nombre
suffisant de militaires mais vous dans
l'action quotidienne il ya très très peu
de soldats par rapport à ce qu'il a à
faire
l'afghanistan c'est à peu près la taille
du texas donc il ya des déserts des
montagnes très haute du désert aride pas
de rôlistes par l'infrastructure
exactement une situation très difficile
et à l'époque quand j'étais sur place il
y avait peut-être environ deux mille
hommes sur place sur le terrain en
dehors des camps militaires et donc
donc on était très peu c'est clair mais
en plus au niveau du quartier général il
y avait énormément de bureaucratie et à
tel point qu'il était difficile
d'obtenir des approbations pour tout
simplement sortir de la base et pour
aller sur le terrain justement à ce qui
est très étonnant aussi c'est que le
matériel moderne n'est pas utilisée par
exemple un moment vous réclamez des
hélicoptères et on vous dit qu'un appât
il ya plein d'hélicoptères tout neufs
comme ça qui sont sur un tarmac c'est
incroyable ça
en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que
quand on demandait du soutien rien pour
aller quelque part on ne pouvait pas
aller en voiture est bien ce moment là
on nous répondait l'écouté ya pas
d'hélicoptère disponibles fut ensuite
vous sortiez du bâtiment tout simplement
et vous regardiez de vous voyez que des
hélicoptères toute une série
d'hélicoptères des hélicoptères qu'on
aurait pu utiliser et donc ce qu'il
fallait qu'on fasse c'est qu'on
n'utilise ce doux sont disposés à savoir
des camions et des 4 4 voilà déjà se
pose la question que pose son livre
c'est à dire est ce que tout ça c'est
l'incompétence de la main américaine ou
est-ce qu'au contraire il ya une volonté
de ne pas attraper des mecs parce que
bon puis surtout c'est peut-être pas la
vraie guerre là tout de suite on va la
faire parce qu'on est obligé de passer
par là est la vraie guerre elle est
poussée sera dans dix minutes alors le
plus incroyable dans votre bouquin c'est
l'incapacité à attraper les terroristes
par exemple le mollah osmani qu'est le
numéro un des militaires talibans il a
été détenu quinze jours à la base de
kandahar après que vous l'ayez à mener
et et avant son transfert vers une
prison afghane et ensuite il a acheté
son évasion pour cent cinquante mille
dollars
en liquide et il est parti au pakistan
la bon certes
c'était une source de frustration
extrême pour nous faut bien dire en fait
nous on était habillé on portaient des
burqas et on devait se déplacer en
étaient déguisés en femmes afghanes
donc on a mis nos risques en vie et on a
fini par rattraper ce type qui était un
type terrible qui était responsable de
la mort de biens des personnes et comme
je vous le disais donc une fois qu'on
attrape quelqu'un est bien bien
évidemment on le passe au grill on veut
l'entendre et ensuite c'est fini mais
après quand on a entendu qu'ils avaient
été relâchés il ya un afghan qui est
venu nous voir ils vous ai dit vous
saisissent pas possible on n'a pas
relâché ce type c'est complètement
incroyable c'est incroyable alors le
mollah omar c'est pareil c'est à dire
qu'ils étaient positionnés par satellite
vous dites on avait son numéro de
portable on avait sans le numéro de sa
toyota on avait le nom de son chauffeur
on avait tout l'été complètement repérer
et et aucune arme n est allé s'emparer
de lui
nous a dit
là où on pensait qu'il était mais s'il a
réussi à survivre aussi longtemps c'est
tout simplement parce qu'ils se déplacer
rapidement ils passaient jamais plus
d'un jour ne manquent pas et on nous a
dit qu il pensait qu'il savait la 8ème
et le problème c'était que cet endroit
n'était pas accessible en voiture et
donc il a fallu qu'on rendra la base et
qu'on demande des hélicoptères est donc
là comme je vous le disais les
hélicoptères étaient alignés
indisponible et donc ils ne nous ont
jamais dit non mais en fait il ne joue
jamais dit oui non plus pendant et ça a
duré plusieurs jours et puis voilà or la
question qu'il se pose voilà encore une
fois simple cafouillage de l'armée ou
alors volonté d'attendre les élections
américaines pour arrêter le mollah omar
ben laden mais là on n'y aux élections
américaines donc c'est pas ça je crois
qu'on n'a aucune envie d'attraper bin
laden je pense que on sait où il est on
sait à peu près où il est mais il est
une telle représentation de dire est
symbolique de la menace terroriste que
la trappe éprouveraient au fond qu on
est en mesure de juguler cette menace
terroriste et je crois que personne ne
souhaite ne serait ce que par exemple
quand on voit par exemple à tora bora on
a laissé partir je dire lorsqu'on a
lancé une attaque terrestre contre tora
bora donc en décembre 2001 on sait déjà
maintenant aussi mine laden était déjà
parti et on n'avait pas du tout fermé la
frontière avec le pakistan
l'ate a pris un coup sur la tête là ce
soir
oui et non parce que en fait on imagine
toujours le pire est vachement rencontre
qu'il faut multiplier par 1000 et qu'on
est encore en dessous de la vérité
respect que vous avez complètement
raison
sésame apporter plus de preuves que ça
tu nous décrit un sas est en voyage
je peux vous dire c'est que si je savais
où il était planquée moi j'irai le
chercher ça ne fait aucun doute
je pense qu'il est encore en vie mais je
pense qu'il est quelque part au pakistan
et je pense qu en fait le truc c'est
qu'on n'a pas envie de rentrer au
pakistan ce bien merci en tous les cas
merci d'avoir été avec nous
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus